- What's like your proudest moment?
'cause there, as a single mom and,
and you play, we're
gonna get to the movie.
Or the series,
but you play, she's a
single mom in the beginning.
- Yes. - And, and you're,
you've been a single mom.
- Yes. - So like, what's
your proudest moment?
'cause it's hard.
To be there for everything.
To hold down a job to, - It's super hard.
And you know, when you're
young, I was very young
and I, for example, now that I'm 51,
I think we talked about it
a little bit when we were,
the last time that I saw you. - Yeah.
- It's like, you know,
I wish I had done things a
little bit, you know, different
because I didn't know I was young.
I was 20 years old with
Manolo, when I had Manolo,
so I was like, kind of like
raising myself at the same time.
So what, I mean, I should
have been going to therapy
or somebody should have been guiding me.
But I'm so proud that
he turned out amazing
and super hard-working. - Yeah.
- And that he, you know, that he wants
to do things in life, and
he's excited about life.
I think that's what all mothers,
you know, wish for. - Yeah. Yeah.
And just polite and respectful.
- [Sophia] Yes, very.
- I'm like, that's my thing.
I'm like, if anything you
can be any of the things,
but just kind would be good.
- Kind. - Yeah.
- Be kind to, to other people.
And my, my, I mean, I, I
don't have anything bad
to say about my son,
so I did a great job. (Kelly laughs)
- I love it. (Sophia laughs)
You gotta be proud of that.
So wait, I wanna show a couple
old photos of y'all together.
So this, first is this Look at,
- [Sophia] Oh!
- [Kelly] Look at you!
- [Sophia] Oh my god. I
think that was in Miami.
Some Halloween or something.
- [Kelly] Well, that's a full circle.
- [Sophia] Yeah.
- You're talking about a character - Yeah.
- In Miami. - Yeah, in Miami. Yeah.
I remember, I think that was
around the time one time like,
I was dropping him to school
and he turned around,
and said to me, mom, don't
forget that tomorrow,
it's like the parents teacher
thing. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm like, yeah, sure. I know.
He is like, and then he
was gonna close the door
and he turned around and said,
don't forget to dress like a mom.
(audience laughs)
I was like, I was like,
I don't even, I'm like, wait,
don't just say that
and got out of the car.
What does that even mean?
- My son says things to
me about my wardrobe.
He literally made me change
for my girl's night out,
just going out to dinner.
He was like, oh, so
you're gonna wear that?
And I was like, damn!
I was like, (audience laughs)
- Well then you're worse than me.
Because at least I was in my twenties.
I was like 23 when he told me that.
(Kelly laughs)
- You're like, I should
be killing it right now.
No, wait. That's what
made, they're honest kids.
I love it.
There's, there's also this one though,
in his favorite 101 Dalmatian
Speedo, which is so great.
(Sophia laughs)
Like that's, where are y'all? What beach?
- No, that's Columbia. I was at the beach.
That's my cousin, Joey.
And we're just like at the,
you know, the local beach in,
in Colombia, and Manolo there.
You know. (Sophia laughs)
- I love it.
- Oh, I haven't seen that picture.
- It's so crazy to see
that they're small. Yeah.
- I know. Now he's big.
- [Kelly] Yeah.